see collectivists see the state as the
source of our morals and our families
obstacles standing between individuals
and their master that's exactly what's
happening with Alfie Evans where
bureaucrats are standing between parents
and their child saying that they know
best that a child has to die because
they know better than the parents do
collectivist they there's a reason that
Karl Marx abhorred the traditional
family let's just say that he saw it as
a capitalist institution based on
capital and on private gain he openly
called for abolition of the family
there's a reason Stalin trained Soviet
youth to become pioneers that's what he
called them emissaries of the state who
are told that the highest good involves
ratting out your own family members at 1
1932 Soviet trial a father actually
cried out to his son it's me your father
and the son replied yes he used to be my
father but I no longer consider him my
father I'm not acting as a son but as a
pioneer Stalin used to go around
Soviet Russia talking about this story
and using it as an example of good
behavior he breaking down the family is
a precondition to building up the state